that's right
my
okay
yes
okay
i think
so
uh
okay
okay
oh
yes
is
thank you will the queue still be we'll
start here in two minutes or something
to that effect
sounds good thank you
now i don't know this is kind of late in
stage but it might be a good idea if you
can
turn the volume down a little bit in
your room uh it might be helpful
for that echo when uh the operator or
some of the this question or speak
okay thanks
we're going to open the phone line let
me know
it's open now okay all right thank you
for being here
uh we are going to have a press
conference today announcing
uh apt41 which is advanced persistent
threat
uh we're going to have four speakers uh
we're gonna start out by the deputy
attorney general
uh then we're gonna be followed by the
d.c
u.s attorney michael sherwin followed by
the fbi deputy director
david bowdich and then assistant
director in charge of the
washington field office fbi james dawson
also on stage but not speaking but
available for q a
is the assistant attorney general for
national security john demers
the way that the press conference will
work is they will each come out and make
brief remarks
we'll ask the operator to open the line
for questions follow
the operator's instructions on how to do
that all questions are coming in through
the phone line because this is a virtual
press conference
the you'll get one question and if you
need a follow-up just re-cue
but we're probably not going to get
through all of the questions
in the initial phase of the press
conference but we are
doing immediately following the press
conference
when the when the principals leave and
the cameras go down those on the phone
line are welcome to remain behind
for a case briefing and then we will get
to all of your questions
so we're going to be back in about a
minute so i'd like
operator please keep the keep the line
open and we'll be right back and we'll
go right into a start
thank you
all right well good morning thanks for
being here today
i'm jeff rosen and with me our fbi
deputy director david bowditch
assistant attorney general for national
security john demers
acting u.s attorney for the district of
columbia michael sherwin
and acting assistant director in charge
of the fbi's washington d.c field office
james dawson we're here today to
announce
coordinated wide-ranging actions to
disrupt the malicious cyber activities
of a group commonly referred to as
advanced persistent threat 41 or apt-41
as well as a related international
criminal enterprise involving apt-41
actors
cyber security experts have referred to
apt-41's activities as one of the
broadest campaigns
by chinese cyber espionage actors in
recent years
we are announcing today multiple efforts
to disrupt these activities first and
foremost
is that we have unsealed three
indictments that
collectively charge five chinese
nationals with computer hacking
and charge two malaysian nationals for
helping some of those hackers
target victims and sell the fruits of
their hacking
our charges allege two distinct
categories of criminal conduct
first as the core of apt 41's computer
hacking
the chinese defendants targeted well
over
100 victims worldwide
in a variety of industries and sectors
that are sadly
part of the standard target list for
chinese hackers
these criminal acts were turbocharged by
a sophisticated technique referred to as
a supply chain attack
in which the chinese hackers compromised
software providers
software that providers around the world
had and modified
the provider's code to install back
doors that enabled
further hacks against the software
provider's customers
second and as an additional method of
making money
several of the chinese defendants
compromised the networks of video game
companies worldwide
that's a billion dollar industry and
defrauded them
of in-game resources two of the chinese
defendants stand accused with two
malaysian defendants
of selling those resources on the black
market
through their illicit website
now in addition to these unsealed
indictments
i'm pleased to announce that through the
cooperation of the malaysian
law enforcement authorities the two
malaysian defendants
were arrested on sunday evening and now
face
extradition proceedings so we have the
indictments and two arrests
identifying those responsible and
holding them account
is our primary mission but criminal
investigation and prosecution alone
are not enough to make the internet
safer
so there's a third part of today's
announcement
specifically in addition to these
criminal charges and the two arrests
the department of justice and the fbi
have been working with
seven private sector partners
including microsoft facebook google
verizon media and others to identify
and neutralize the computer
infrastructure
that apt41 uses to conduct its crimes
its virtual private servers malware
malicious domains and other tools
we have done this through a combination
of public and private actions including
technical measures to block this threat
actor from accessing victims computer
systems
issuing a public safety announcement
outlining their tactics techniques and
procedures
to aid network defenders and by taking
control of or otherwise
disabling their accounts pursuant to
court orders
and terms of service violations
the bottom line is that we have used
every tool
at the department's disposal to disrupt
these apt41 activities
now ideally i would be thanking chinese
law enforcement authorities for their
cooperation in the matter and the five
chinese hackers would now be in custody
awaiting trial
unfortunately the record of recent years
tells us
that the chinese communist party has a
demonstrated history of choosing a
different path
that of making china safe for their own
cyber criminals
as long as they help with its goals of
stealing intellectual property and
stifling freedom
less than two months ago assistant
attorney general demers was at this
podium
to announce an indictment in another
hacking case in which the chinese
government tolerated the defendant's
criminal activity
because those defendants were willing to
work on behalf of the chinese
intelligence services
and here we are again in this case one
of the chinese defendants
is accused of boasting to a colleague
that he was quote very close to the
ministry of state security
and would be protected quote unless
something very big happens
the hacker and his associates agreed not
to quote touch domestic stuff anymore
we know the chinese authorities to be at
least
as able as the law enforcement
authorities here and in like-minded
states to enforce laws against computer
intrusions
but they don't do so
but know this no country can be
respected as a global leader while
paying only lip service to the rule of
law
and without taking steps to disrupt
brazen criminal acts like this
no responsible government knowingly
shelters cyber criminals that target
victims
worldwide in acts of rank
theft responsible nations
not only condemn criminal conduct they
root it out and punish it
responsible nations disavow criminals
within their borders and bring them to
justice
responsible nations work with other
countries law enforcement authorities to
ensure that justice is served in a court
of law
the prc has done none of these things
so you can take three additional
observations from this conference today
first the chinese government has the
power to help stop crimes like this
second the chinese government has made a
deliberate choice to allow its citizens
to commit commuter and
computer intrusions and attacks around
the world because these actors will also
help the prc
but third the department of justice
will do everything it can to disrupt
these crimes
by exposing the techniques tactics and
procedures used by apt
41 by enabling the private sector to
disable them
and by working with our law enforcement
colleagues all around the globe
to arrest the hackers when we can
as with the two today we appreciate our
partnerships with the private sector
as i said in this instance including
microsoft facebook google and verizon
media
and our partnerships with foreign law
enforcement partners
who have been a force multiplier in
these fights against
international criminals such
partnerships
send a clear message that governments
and the private sector
are prepared to work together to defend
against significant
cyber threats today
on top of all the measures i've
mentioned already we are exposing this
threat to the international community
to cyber security experts and to the
greater public
and we will never stop pursuing the uh
individuals responsible for these
alleged criminal acts
here and abroad and anywhere they travel
now at this point i will turn the podium
over to acting u.s attorney
michael sherwin who will discuss the
allegations in the indictments
in greater detail
thank you sir all right uh ladies and
gentlemen the scope and sophistication
of the crimes alleged in these three
indictments that we unsealed this week
are really unprecedented
for several reasons as previously
mentioned
hundreds of corporations and thousands
of individual accounts were targeted by
these chinese hackers
and causing upwards estimated millions
of dollars in damages
now what makes these indictments more
troubling
and more interesting to some degree is
the fact that
we now see these hallmarks of the
hackers targeting in addition to the
the standard corporations that were
targeted business institutions
universities
we also see online gaming companies
which the deputy attorney general just
mentioned
is a billion dollar industry so this is
a new
target rich environment in which hackers
are targeting and
as we'll we'll go through with these
indictments the chinese hackers working
in concert with the two malaysians to
not only hack into these online digital
gaming companies but then
essentially fence and sell digital
currencies
tokens coins on gaming platforms to
third parties
and essentially victimizing these online
gaming companies
and laundering those proceeds back to
the chinese so the first indictment
ladies and gentlemen
uh the zhang indictment deals with two
chinese nationals and there's really two
criminal schemes related to this first
indictment
the first criminal scheme is the basic
brute force type hacking that we've seen
in other cases
but this this scheme also involved as
the deputy attorney general just
mentioned
the supply chain attacks in which the
chinese hackers in a very sophisticated
way
would hack into software companies
insert malicious malware
that software would then would be sold
to innocent third parties
for corporate use but these the the
malware
served as the the software was a trojan
horse which allowed the hackers to then
get into
the third-party databases and steal more
proprietary information
and and that's uh that's that's seen and
elicited throughout that first
indictment in addition to that
that first criminal scheme that we
outlined in that first indictment
we also see another scheme in which
these two
chinese hackers were working in concert
with the two malaysians
in which they were targeting online
gaming companies throughout the world
and once they would target these online
gaming companies as many people know
especially if you have kids
there's a lot of coins tokens digital
currency involved in a lot of these
online games they would steal
that digital currency they would then
work with the two malaysians
that are cited in indictment number two
that would then essentially
fence and sell that stolen digital
currency
online to other innocent third parties
so this is again troubling because we
see this as unfortunately a new area in
which hackers are exploiting
and it's a billion dollar industry and
i'm sure this isn't the end we're going
to see much more of this criminal
conduct unfortunately
the third indictment ladies and
gentlemen deal with three chinese
nationals
very similar to the uh the allegations
in the first indictment with the two
chinese nationals
uh very basic allegations of
brute force hacking but what's
interesting in the third indictment
ladies and gentlemen is there's
reference to
shangduk 40 which is a chinese corporate
entity which is closely linked
to the chinese government does work for
them and it has close contacts with the
chinese people's republic army and also
the chinese
military security apparatus so in terms
of that third indictment we see hacking
we steal the theft the proprietary
information
and uh again hundreds of corporations
targeted throughout the world
with millions in loss so these three
indictments ladies and gentlemen
essentially are trying to telegraph to
the world that the
department of justice the fbi the u.s
attorney's office will
fix find and indict cyber criminals in
any corner of the world
be it malaysia china uh eastern europe
western europe and bringing them to
justice here in the district of columbia
without much more to say i want to first
of all thank the
ausas that were involved in this case
and the the united states attorney's
office and also the
amazing and extraordinary work of the
fbi and uh working this case up because
it was very sophisticated and involved a
tremendous amount of effort by the
bureau
so right now i'm going to turn over the
podium to deputy director david bowdich
thank you
all right thank you mike
all right good morning i've been up here
all too often
with my partners from the department of
justice talking
about hackers in particular chinese
hackers
and here we are again we're here today
to tell these hackers and the chinese
government officials who turned a blind
eye to their activities
that their actions are once again
unacceptable
and we will call them out publicly we've
been fighting the cyber threat for years
now
and all too often it's been a game of
whack-a-mole
we investigate one hacker group
and we quickly uncover another hacker
group
we disrupt one nation state adversary
targeting our infrastructure and our
intellectual property
and very quickly we are oftentimes
exposing another
side of that that nation-state actor or
another nation-state actor as well
some days it seems like a never-ending
battle but cyber is one of our highest
priority in fact the fbi's new
enterprise strategy highlights how
important it is to us
the fbi's priority number two is to
protect to the united states
against foreign intelligence espionage
and cyber operations our number three
priority
is to combat significant cyber criminal
activity and we've been taking a closer
look
at what the fbi can bring to this fight
our cyber strategy in a nutshell
is designed to impose both risk
and consequences on our adversaries
in plain english we want to make it more
difficult
and more painful for hackers and
criminals
to do what they're doing and the best
way for us to do that
is by leveraging our unique authorities
our unique capabilities
and our enduring relationships not just
in the us
but throughout the world we want to
build on the innovation that has helped
the fbi
and our partners adapt and evolve to
meet the
the evolution of threats throughout the
past century
we've got to change the cost-benefit
analysis of criminals and nation-state
actors
who believe they can compromise united
states networks
steel u.s financial and intellectual
property
and hold our crim critical
infrastructure at risk
all without impo risks to themselves
indictments are only one way in which we
do that
but often that's all we can do
we indict the criminals we come up here
on stage
and we call them out publicly this time
as the deputy attorney general stated
earlier
due to a large do in a large part to the
efforts of our folks here but also in a
large part to our malaysian
law enforcement counterparts we have two
people in custody
and we are seeking their extradition to
bring them to the u.s
to face these charges the cyber threat
is not a problem
sorry the cyber threat is not a problem
that any one agency
can address by itself so central to our
strategy is the role the fbi plays
as an indispensable partner to our
federal counterparts
our foreign adversaries and our private
sector partners
we want to make sure we're doing
everything we can to help our partners
do what they need to do and the private
sector
and the partnerships that have been
developed over time cannot be
understated they're an incredibly
important component
in the cyber fight that means using our
role as a lead federal law enforcement
agency with law enforcement and
intelligence responsibilities to not
only pursue
their actions but those of the
adversaries overseas
to enable our partners to defend
networks
to attribute malicious activities to
sanction bad behavior
and to take the fight to our adversaries
overseas as much as we possibly can
to that end later today we will be
distributing a flash message
to our private sector partners and our
foreign partners
a flash message essentially provides the
expertise necessary and the technical
expertise necessary for them
to defend their own networks we believe
it will be helpful in not only detecting
but mitigating apt
41's malicious activities before i wrap
up i want to remind you
what i have said almost every time we've
been up here at the podium when it comes
to an indictment of chinese hackers
our concern is not with the chinese
people
our concern is not with the chinese
americans
but specifically our concern is with the
chinese
communist party confronting this threat
effectively does not mean we should not
do business
with the chinese it does not mean we
should not host
chinese students and it does not mean we
should not welcome
chinese visitors or co-exist
with china on the world stage
as a country what it does mean is that
when china
violates our criminal laws and our
international norms
we will call them out we're going to
work together with our partners at home
and abroad in law enforcement and in the
private sector
to stop brazen cyber crime and hold
people accountable
the cyber threat is daunting but with
the tailored approaches that we've put
together in each situation to bring
together
the right talent and the patriotic
people
their tools and the authorities we've
been provided at the right times
we have the ability to understand and
combat the cyber threat
so let me talk about those people i want
to quickly call out our special agents
our analysts our computer scientists
and quite frankly the prosecutors that
worked on this case
and work on these cases on a day-to-day
basis these cases are tedious
they are detailed they require a
significant level of expertise
and they require more than anything
tenacity and i want to thank them for
their work
for the american people to the hackers
i want to tell you whether you're in the
u.s or whether you're overseas
just because you have not yet seen an
indictment
does not mean that there is not a
prosecutor
working with a group of agents and
supporting cast
putting together an indictment for you
as we speak
thank you next up i want to introduce
our acting as
assistant director in charge of the
washington field office jim dawson
good morning and thank you deputy
director bowditch
today's actions charging five china
based and two malaysia-based hackers
demonstrate the tenacity of the fbi's
washington field office
and our government partners to ensure
all criminals are held accountable for
their actions
no matter their location we are
committed to bringing justice
to all victims of cyber crimes
these hackers compromised the computer
networks of more than 100 companies
around the world these intrusions
allowed hackers to steal source code
customer account data and personally
identifiable
information using their access the
hackers not only compromised an
individual company
but also use their access to compromise
the company's customers
extending the effects of their crimes
these actions were often conducted using
maintaining
and communicating with computer and
internet infrastructure
located in the united states
several of these defendants also
defrauded video game companies through
manipulation of in-game resources to
increase their illicitly obtained
income these for-profit criminal
activities took place
with the tacit approval of the
government of the people's republic
of china this investigation
is another example of the blended threat
increasingly seen
in cyber investigations to address these
threats the fbi brings together
its expertise in criminal national
security
and cyber investigations to bring
justice
to these actors who attempt to take
advantage of the supposed anonymity
and lack of geographical limits of
cyberspace
the companies and individuals victimized
by these criminals are located
around the world their crimes
transcended borders
which is another reason the fbi and our
partners
must work together to bring these
individuals to justice
no matter where they might reside
in this case we are immensely grateful
to the malaysian government for their
willingness to assist us
with the arrest and extradition of two
of these hackers
in addition to the malaysian government
we would also like to thank the private
sector companies
who have taken proactive measures to
harden their network vulnerabilities
utilized by these actors
notably we are unable to extend any
gratitude
to the chinese communist party or to the
government of the people's republic of
china
which was unwilling or unable to address
the egregious
cyber criminal activity of its citizens
as always the fbi will continue to work
with its partners
to identify those who conduct cyber
attacks against our nation
bring their actions to light and hold
them responsible
wherever they are thank you and i'll
yield the podium to death
attorney general rosen
so let me let me add my thanks to
both the fbi for the outstanding work by
the
the entire team there and to our lawyers
at both the national security division
and the u.s attorney's office
it's it's uh outstanding work and on
behalf of the department i want to
express my appreciation for that as well
i think at this point we'll be happy to
see if there are questions
thank you we will now begin the question
and answer session to ask a question you
may press star
then 1 on your telephone keypad if
you're using the speakerphone
please pick up your handset before
pressing the keys
to withdraw your question please press
star
then 2. we ask that you please
state who you are directing your
question too
at this time we will pause momentarily
to assemble our roster
and our first question will come from
eric tucker with the associated press
please go ahead
yes hi thank you so much um i i suppose
this question is
perhaps best directed to uh the uh
united states attorney mr sherwin
i was wondering if you could please
elaborate on two different uh things one
is the the
connection that you allege between this
hacking group and the chinese government
i'm trying to determine whether it's a
sort of a test connection or more of a
direct link and also for
sort of the non-profit hacking related
efforts
what do you think is the the primary
motive that you're seeing in terms of
the
the intrusions that are targeting
universities and think tanks and
elements like that thank you
mike come on up sure yes uh
so i want to start off by saying in
neither and any of these three
indictments do we
blatantly allege that these acts were
state spots
or however the caveat is this in those
indictments you have to ask
ask two questions one who is doing the
hacking and who is being hacked
now the general nature of that hacking
was for personal benefit with those
defendants however
if you parse through those indictments
you're going to see some targets that
were not corporations
you see targets such as pro-democracy
groups you see targets such as
democracy think tanks and universities
now
a hacker for profit is not going to hack
a pro-democracy group
this is a breadcrumb that shows that
these individuals were working for
private personal gain yes but they also
were proxies
that's a conclusion you could draw for
the chinese government why can we say
that we can say that for a few reasons
one
as alleged in the indictment some of the
lead defendants boasted and mentioned
that they had communications and
contacts with
the state apparatus of china they also
mentioned that uh and again i believe
it's in the third indictment the jang
indictment that
it is okay to target externally
internationally but
a no-go domestically so that's showing
that there's some tacit approval
or there's some tacit direction that
they're getting from the
chinese government i believe did i
address
all of your questions sir
okay thank you and the next question
will come from dustin boltz with the
wall street journal please go ahead
all right thanks so much for doing the
call um two quick questions
on the so-called supply chain attacks um
that seemed like a pretty interesting
mechanism used here can you just give us
more details about sort of
how widespread this that was in the
campaign or how many of the victims
were impacted by that uh approach of
compromising the software
companies that were then injecting
updates to third parties and then
on the um companies that were helpful in
the investigation
facebook microsoft google and verizon um
any more details just about how that
assistance worked how long they were
involved
and you know is there any evidence that
any of them were themselves targeted or
compromised by this campaign
okay so so those those are those are
important aspects why don't we take them
separately mike you want to address
first the supply chain attacks because
that is a very important element here
yeah as again i'll be brief but as
mentioned earlier these supply 10
attacks did occur in the conduct related
to these indictments however
this isn't the first time we've seen
that this isn't a novel type of a
hacking attack
we've seen this before the past several
years so that's not novel but it is
sophisticated
uh and most of that was as mentioned
malware would be inserted into that
software that would then be sold to
third parties
that creates back doors so you could
further exploit those customers that
purchase that software
john you want to take the part about the
uh cooperation in the private sector or
sure i mean i think on that we're not
going to say more than what was
uh what we've already said publicly and
uh
and in the indictment in terms of the
cooperation we've gone from the private
sector but we're obviously very grateful
both
to those who were named and those who
were not named
and and i think i'll just add in the big
picture that's an important part of what
we do in these kind of situations is
is the partnership with the private
sector is extremely important
to our ability to both deal with the
cases and try to try to protect the
internet
next question
thank you and that question will come
from nick schifrin with pbs
please go ahead thank you very much for
for doing
thank you very much for doing this i
wanted to go back to the intersection of
espionage and
politics can you talk more about the mss
connection whether
you believe that this is a real
connection or whether
it was just a bit of a brag and when you
say proxy
can you talk more about the nature of
the targeting not only against
pro-democracy hong kong activists but
also india
and vietnamese computer networks that
seems to be two governments that the
chinese
have had difficulties with and the us
has been trying to align with
recently thanks
sure briefly i'll essentially say what i
stated before so look there's no
explicit allegation that this was state
sponsored however
people that are hacking for profit do
not target some of the entities that are
listed in those indictments for example
the pro-democracy groups
the other universities for example in
that third indictment
there was hacking of essentially
thousands of students at a taiwanese
university
that is a hallmark that is a trademark
of espionage that's what espionage
that's what
intelligence service use to harvest data
individuals that they could spot and
target
again these are just this is evidence
circumstantial when you build it all
together when you follow all the
breadcrumbs those breadcrumbs
in general a theory could be that that
leads to the ministry of state security
yeah i think uh the the u.s attorney
answered that very well and
there's not a lot i have to add i do say
i would say that as i mentioned earlier
we are seeking the extradition
of these two malaysian subjects whether
or not any other
country gets involved in that and tries
to block that in any way
will be interesting to watch i do want
to follow up also on the private sector
aspect that was asked earlier
look the reality is for many decades
we've talked about our private sector
partners
first with law enforcement and then in
the intelligence community
but today the private sector
partnerships that we have developed
throughout the country
are absolutely essential and just
because
we have some very talented people
working in the private sector
does not mean they are not every bit as
patriotic
as those of us working in the u.s
government
and the next question will come from
david spont
with fox news please go ahead sure thank
you for taking my question everybody
this is for fbi deputy director david
bowditch sir
i consent your frustration when you came
up to the podium
and you talked a little bit about this
being like whack-a-mole
my question for you is you know when you
deal with people
in china and you arrest people in china
they're not playing ball
and they're not helping you guys out to
extradite these people i mean sure two
from malaysia are going to come back
but talk to me about the frustration to
put these wanted posters out here
countless wanted posters
and not have any help from anybody in
china to get these people to the united
states
sure i can address at least part of that
question first off it is incredibly
frustrating and i think that the deputy
attorney general's points earlier about
asking for chinese assistance
and relying upon them it was a very
salient point for all of us to think
through
as far as our counterintelligence
mission and our cyber mission
yes much of our work is done against
chinese communist party individuals or
chinese communist party
in affiliated individuals yes it's
incredibly frustrating
and the reality is there are those out
there who do not believe
indictments are effective i would
counter that strongly
for many reasons first and foremost
we know about the travel of some
individuals who participate in this type
of activity
they know that if they are indicted
they are at great risk if they travel
outside their country
we have proven that through the long arm
of the law and that may sound like an
overused phrase but i truly believe in
it
in these international cases and so it
does restrict their travel
it also uh puts them on notice
and it has been successful in many cases
not just with chinese nation state
adversarial actors
but also with other adversarial nation
state actors where we are able to
actually reach them
bring them back to the u.s and and
run them through the adjudication
process is it frustrating yes it
is are folks dogged and tenacious and
will they continue to be
yes they will let me supplement that
with just two quick points
this is a case where thanks to our our
partnership with the malaysian
government
we have two people who perhaps thought
they were beyond our reach
and they've they've been arrested we
still have to have them extradited but
uh people who think that that uh
their safe havens you know need to think
pretty carefully about that because as i
said in my initial remarks
we will pursue people not just here but
abroad wherever they travel
and this is a case or a set of three
cases really
in which the victims are worldwide and
affected countries
all over the globe so um
there will be many people interested
in in finding these defendants
and we hope to find the opportunity to
try them in a court of law
and present the evidence beyond a
reasonable doubt
one more
thank you and that question will come
from kadeem
schubert with financial times please go
ahead
uh hi there thank you for doing this
call um i had a question for
acting u.s attorney sherwin can you
just tell us a little bit about the
compromised government networks in
india and vietnam what was you know
targeted or
stolen or disrupted there and also about
the attempt to compromise government
networks in the uk
and what the hackers were targeting
there
at this point we cannot go
exceed the four corners of those
indictments to get into details
obviously as the case proceeds
more details would come out but at this
point uh we just have to stand out the
allegations and yes those nations
infrastructures were targeted and
obviously as previously mentioned i
think in a question a couple of minutes
ago here
those nations are not friends of china
so it's no
mystery or it's not surprising that some
of their infrastructure was targeted
so so i hate to end on one that that uh
we have some limits on what we can say
so why don't we do one more
thank you and that question will come
from alex mellon with abc news
please go ahead
uh my question i just wanted to ask do
you have a sense of the extradition
uh timing in terms of you know the
malaysian government was obviously
very cooperative in arresting them but
do you have any sense on when
these two malaysian businessmen will see
the inside of the u.s courtroom
i think this is uh a somewhat
complicated subject but we'll see if
john demers can can offer any thoughts
well
i don't want to get ahead of the process
there in malaysia obviously they
uh these two defendants will have a
right to raise um
you know whatever claims they'd like to
try to fight the extradition
i imagine they will try to fight the
extradition uh and we'll just have to
let the
malaysian process uh play itself out but
it certainly will be
months uh before they get over here but
in the meantime
they've been arrested over there thanks
well thanks very much everybody and let
me just mention that we do plan
a backgrounder as as well so uh well i'm
going to have to depart
some of the folks that can provide uh
many more of the specific details and
answer some of the back address some of
the background things will now be
available
and we'll go to that
thank you once again if you'd like to
ask a question
please press star then one all right
thank you everybody for joining this
marks the end of the formal part of the
press conference the cameras can
shut down now and then in about one
minute we're